hello Angela and this is Greg Alva here
on the real rejects YouTube channel with
me today is Casey Spivey personality on
screen rent talented actress supermodel
supermodel super bikini men's health
[Laughter]
first female bikini mom you're the
workouts you guys want to do you uh you
like to laugh yeah I'm transitioning
right now thank you
there's this YouTube channel out there a
guy named I call him a dick the one or a
dick the 1 or V dick the one have you
ever done try not to laugh challenge if
you feel like laughing fight it and if
you lose we just continue it's not a
real competition we just keep trying we
keep trying to hold together we just
keep trying to hold together it's not a
one and done it's not a real challenge
ok smile like this like with my like
with like a look like what counts as the
laugh you know
oh my god haha like a release of air
yeah got it
how do you define laughter where is this
too funny
killing it I can hear you guys laughing
at oh yeah when big black book
I have Sarah
[Music]
it's already
[Music]
[Music]
Luke he killed me with the stun stun he
can't use a Stein
yeah guys look yeah yeah look guys look
look hey disconnected yeah guys thanks
for watching guys James Dean is from an
actual porno that's not advertiser from
Brits is great browsers hi gays
my [ __ ] life [ __ ] what is what is
the 10 most offensive gentleman ever
written the phony Africa for mosquito
nets that every year we could say
millions of mosquitoes from dying
needlessly of ate chocolate Jesus the
figure this out even though I am a
genius okay
I'm militaristic did anybody in this
room
listen instead I are not really good at
where I love war a certain way but only
way
[Music]
whoa I thought there was a dog okay
[Music]
they were like cut at all the door
opened
[Music]
they're gonna be brilliant filmmakers
one day listen I made plenty of those
flashlights I think this is something
else that's a flashlight Oh flesh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
good I hope you feel in my flow if not
each we may be late for my show I'm a
real deep cold so don't give a [ __ ] you
poke [ __ ] if they're like my
second cup going don't stop
[Music]
[Music]
I wanna [ __ ] die that deserves a
laugh
[Music]
yeah difficult no one was prepared for
terrorists money to blow signs of planes
that's horrible
no but a lot of people were surprised
[Music]
okay oh my gosh resigned because these
two are singing another Street
[Music]
[Music]
yeah just watch the trailer inspect oh
why is it I obviously one yeah you
obviously one you didn't crack one time
one time you know honestly sometimes I
never know sometimes I'm like these are
gonna be boring and easy to sit through
and then this was a pretty funny one
actually there were some really funny
ones in there I left it nothing nothing
God no it got me I'm not inviting me
laughs I didn't laugh at the one about
the mosquitos who this is poured on the
porn when I I just don't understand is
that an actual porno I'm sure it is
and yeah listen somebody did because
somebody saw it as somebody somebody
thought it was great let me found it I
heard there's a whole video of the Darth
Vader with the trunk voice oh yeah yeah
if someone took a bunch of Trump quotes
and put it over that's two I'm too close
to home too close to home
he is Darth Vader meets Bane who is this
thing with the person crying over glass
you missed this because so funny is so
complicated but then the door aliens
I was just looking to see if they got
like
yeah oh yeah what was the point of that
his cavity slides down the bowl you have
those funny
I didn't bring down that no well that
got me oh just like you just expecting
like oh he's gonna fall really hard or
something the stuff for people fall
though
yeah that's not funny I can't watch that
stuff they should do it try not to react
to anything yeah when this guy Falls you
can't watch it at all can't watch this I
didn't watch like any of it like I just
was like this the whole the whole time
so much so that I had a migraine the
next day feel good thing we didn't watch
any horror stuff today
well ADAC the one dude I'm proud of you
man
you are so good at finding funny stuff
and putting it in a calm Polish way to
go buddy
it's harder than its way harder than
what I do get hard let me take the back
it's way harder to watch his compilation
than it is to assemble this is this this
part of the job you have no idea how
challenging this stuff is compared to
what you're doing
props mm-hmm Casey Spivey should
probably contact him and like weasel
their way onto the show yeah yeah
obviously you can't remember her name
yeah come on Kelsey give me a break
[Music]
subscribe to a dick the one first off
the real rejects yes to click that
notification bell ding more importantly
follow Casey Spivey at hey underscore
case yeah Casey yeah it's a gravid
twitter and she also has video segments
on screen rent pretty much every day of
the week and instead of doing a film
video with her
that's right out to left